[AUDIO LOGO]
- Thank you all so much
for joining us today. Happy Thursday.
Nice to see everybody
at the Data Science
Hangout. If this is your
first time here today, so nice
to meet you but thank you
all for spending the Thursday with us.
If we haven't met yet,
I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I host the hangout and
lead customer marketing at Posit.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place,
except the week after
next we'll be at the Posit
conference in Chicago so we
won't have a hangout that week.
But I'm excited to get to meet
so many of you there in person.
But anyways if you're watching
this recording at some point in
the future on YouTube
and you are thinking,
I want to join them live,
you can use the link
below in the details
to add it to your calendar too.
But at the hangout,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody. And we love
to hear from everyone,
no matter your years
of experience, titles,
industry, or languages that you
work in too. And every week,
I'm joined by a different
leader from the community who
joins to share their experience
and answer questions from you all.
And so it is totally OK if
you want to just listen in here.
Maybe you're on your lunch
break or you're having to multitask.
But there's always 3 ways you
can jump in and ask questions
or provide your
own perspective.
So you can raise your hand on
Zoom and I'll keep an eye out.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put a
little star next to it if it's
something you want
me to read instead.
And then we also have a
Slido link where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And Caitlin,
if you don't mind sharing
that in the chat right now--
Oh, Hannah got it already.
Awesome, thank you.
But you can ask
questions anonymously there as well.
But with all that, thanks
again so much for joining us.
I'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host today,
Colonel Kris Saling, Director of
Innovation at US Army Human Resources
Command.
And Kris,
I'd love to kick things off
with maybe having you introduce
yourself, and sharing a little
bit about your role today,
and something you like to
do outside of work too.
- [CHUCKLES]
No, that sounds good. And thank
you so much for that Rachael.
So as you said,
I'm the director of innovation
for the US Army Human Resources
Command and everybody always tries
to figure out what that is.
Innovation has become a buzzword.
We always talk about
innovation theater and everything else.
Our job is to be a little
bit of a future concept cell for
the commanding general so that we
can be a little bit more
removed from the daily asks and
tasks and figure out how we're
going to take, and update,
and sometimes transform our processes
to get after those future concepts.
So I have a team that is
predominantly technologists. I
have a lot of data scientists.
I have a cyber guy,
have a networks guy.
I have a human resources
digital transformation subject
matter expert, and a
recruiting team. And
that's just the start
of us. We're a year old.
And I think we're going to
expand by another 10 positions
or so this coming year.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: That's great, thank
you. And outside of work,
what's something
you like to do?
- I like to cook. So
to me, that's my zen.
I'll put on some music and I'll
go in the kitchen and cook something.
- Nice. So I know you said
this is a new team here.
Can you share a little bit
about how the creation of that
team came to be and maybe
how you work with some other
departments across
the army too?
- Yeah. No, it really started
when I was working in--
just for some context,
I've been working out of
the army people space for seven,
going on eight years now,
which is kind of atypical.
But a lot of what
we've been doing is digital modernization
and transformation.
Army came out with the Army
People Strategy, I want to say,
in 2019 or early 2020 that
talked about how we wanted to
modernize how we did
talent management. Pushed a lot,
did a lot of different
pilots and prototypes.
Got a bunch of policies changed.
We did some great stuff there.
And then realized that
we hadn't modernized the
mechanisms to actually get us
to talent management. We were still
basically assigning people and
moving people around using the
same old systems.
And a lot of them really
needed to be updated.
So
we needed a way to look out
and see how we could do that
cohesively rather than just
looking at the individual
processes and the directorates.
So General Drew made the
decision that he was going to
establish the Innovation Cell to solidify
our HRC 2030 vision that we have
and to look at how we're
going to step forward in our
technology and our business
practices to achieve it.
- I see, Catherine, you
had a question in the chat.
Do you want to
jump in here first?
CATHERINE:
It was really just a question
on whether or not all of the
people on your team are in
active duty in the military or
if some of those are
also GS positions,
or what your team
makeup looks like.
- Yeah, it's military
and civilian.
Right now we're mostly military
just because I took my team--
I realigned my team that I
had for talent management with me.
But we've made a couple
civilian hires and we're going
to make a number of other
civilian hires.
- So a question I had
wanted to ask you about is
Katelyn and I were talking
about how you've managed to
kind of break silos between
the different army departments and
getting people to work
together to help achieve the
team's vision.
And I was just wondering
how have you been able to do
that and what tips do you have
for some of us who are maybe
trying to do the same thing and
break silos within
our own organizations?
- I mean one of the
biggest skills that we--
we harp a lot on
command in the military.
But that's not the most
important leadership skill.
One of the most important
things that we consider is
building coalitions.
How do you reach out to
your counterparts and get a whole
bunch of people crashing
together on a common goal or a
common understanding.
I think one of the places
we've had the biggest success with
that is with our data
literacy program.
Because we had a lot
of people with needs,
we had a lot of people who
are looking for more data.
And we were able to pull people
from throughout the army to
look at this as a project and
get it scaled up so now it's
part of a professional
military education.
- Thank you.
I think Mike's question there
kind of touches on this as
well. But Mike, do you
want to expand on that?
- Yeah. And actually, I think
you answered part of it. But
as you're building your team,
and this is a kind of
question that we hear a lot at
Data Science
Hangout, do those team
members already have data
science skills or are they
having to learn as they go?
KRIS SALING: So we had a mix.
One I hired straight out of
grad school out of a Georgetown
Data Science Program. Another
I hired from Notre Dame
in the Computer
Science Program.
So they had a
number of different data skills.
They had to cross-train into
other areas of emphasis.
Obviously,
natural language processing
and text string analysis is big
when you're in
the people space.
One of them came in with
a lot of those skills.
The others are
having to learn it.
And then I have a couple
other folks who were very good
statistical analysts.
Didn't
have the same kind of
experience in building out some
of the applications
we were building.
So we're using a
number of different
training programs, upskilling,
pair coding to try to
get them set on that.
Then I do have some folks who
come in straight from the HR side, very
limited exposure to
data and data science.
And it gave me an opportunity
to test our data literacy
training on them to get them
to ask more intelligent data
questions. Not that
they weren't asking intelligent
questions, but there's less
translation needed between them
and our data folks.
- I'm sure I'll have follow-up
questions in a minute,
but I'll come back then.
[CHUCKLING]
- Patrick, I see you just
put a question in the chat.
Want to jump in here?
PATRICK: Yeah,
thank you, Rachael.
It's sort of a follow-up
to what you just said Kris.
And thank you for being
here. I'm fascinated by this.
You mentioned
text analysis NLP.
What are your key data sources
for bringing that in to the
analytic pipeline and then
also, other data sources,
more quantitatively-focused
stuff?
- So
we use a number of different
commercial products.
We use Hugging Face.
We use a number of other
things you guys are probably familiar
with to help us
at least kind of break
down our taxonomies.
But most of the work that
we're doing comes from our evaluation
entry system where we
are looking at evaluations,
we're looking at duty descriptions,
we're looking at how we
establish our taxonomies
and ontologies for job
competencies.
There are a lot of libraries
out there that we could--
but there's not really a
spacy library out there for
military competency.
So we've had to
practically build our own.
Does that kind of
answer your question?
My answer was all over
the place. [LAUGHS]
PATRICK: No, that's awesome.
And it's wonderful
work you all are doing.
So thank you very much.
- Oh, thank you.
-
And I go back to the
conversation about breaking
down silos a bit, Luke
had asked in the chat,
in such a gigantic operation,
how have you been able to
actually break down those data
silos to get what you need?
-
So the first step we had
to do was convince senior leaders to
be directive. I mean,
it's horrible to say,
you think we're going to want
to cooperate and share but
nobody wants to cooperate
and share their data.
So we went to Secretary
of the Army and said,
I have a directive here that
says all the people in the
people space will share
their people data, period.
So it was our
first people analytics core directive.
We've refreshed
that a couple times.
And we've identified our person
event data environment as kind
of being the semi-official
repository for that data sharing.
We get a lot of people
who are working in that environment. It's
probably something a lot of
you will be familiar with,
it's just a massive
data warehouse with a virtual
machine environment on top
of it that we use to drop
different data sets and to
do different projects. But no,
we had to basically order
everybody to share their data.
-
I'm trying to think how
that might translate to some of
these teams here too.
- Well, I mean, I think
the biggest piece,
we talked about building
coalitions. There's going to be--
we tried to do
some data summits
across the army just to
bring people together and talk about
what they were working on.
And man,
it would be really cool if
we could just get our hands on--
well there's probably somebody in
the room who knows how to
get their hands on that data.
So we started this
little bit of a coalition
talking about, wouldn't it be great
if we could do all this.
And that's how we pitched the
argument to leadership to say, look,
we've got to get here. We've
got to be able to do this.
And we need your
support and endorsement.
Ours was very directive.
But I think if you
have a leader there who
does give you that
champion, that support and endorsement,
that might be a good corollary.
- Definitely. Colter, I see
you had a question in the chat.
Want to jump in here next?
COLTER: Sure. And you actually
just kind of answered it.
But I was wondering if
from your perspective,
if you've seen similar data
modernization efforts happening
either within other commands?
I'm thinking of like a
Futures Command or even within
individual branches within
the army if there are similar
efforts going on?
- Oh, yeah. No,
we've really got a,
it warms my heart, data
modernization trend.
Army Futures Command
is a big partner,
their data science division.
Nate Parker over there is a
big partner of ours in looking at
how we can get more agile
data science. I hate to say agile.
Not in terms of
agile development, but something
that will flex better into
our different requirements.
So we're working with him
and seeing if we can use that
instead of our
current environment.
We've reached out to 18th
Airborne Corps who is using our
Vantage Program which is
built on Palantir Foundry
to do a lot of
their work, a lot of
their data work informing
decisions. We've worked with
the Army AI Integration Center that
is now up at Carnegie Mellon.
We've got a lot of great
partners here. And West Point.
I can't leave out West Point.
Partner and good friend,
Colonel Nick Clark who started
our data literacy training
program that we've incorporated
and taken army-wide.
And I think coming back to
finding those partners in the coalitions,
as we figured out who all
was working in this space,
we've been able to give each
other a hand up when we need
when people need
resources or endorsement.
And it's really made
things spread faster.
- I know we touched on
the data literacy program a few times.
And I was just curious
what does that program look like?
-
So the initial iteration was
just 10 hours of coursework
basically making people better
critical consumers of data.
Oh, hey, Nate's here.
Yes, always got your shout-outs.
Making people better
critical consumers of data.
That's expanded to about a
16-hour course that's going to
be in our basic
professional
military education.
There's a second level that
they're going to get in that
next iteration, which
is more hands-on.
Using the common tools
that you have available,
we'll start folks out just
doing basic statistical
analysis in Excel or
whatever they have access to.
I want to start introducing them
into R and Python so that
it's not scary. We
can learn how to code. We
share some of those
resources.
So if they're interested or
if their branch has opportunities,
they go into level three,
which is where we take
them into some in-depth analytic
training. That walks them
through our data competency model.
And we basically create
learning paths for all the
different things
that they want to do.
If they want to get into
different types of coding.
If they want to do more NLP.
I need more NLP programmers.
[CHUCKLES]
That's always the fun part too
when you talk about NLP with a
bunch of data scientists. You
know who your natural language
processors are, and then you
know who your optimizers are.
Because they're wait,
what are you talking
about non-linear programs for?
- [CHUCKLES]
That actually leads me to
a question that was asked
anonymously was,
how much is R or Python
used in your organization?
- So a majority of our
folks are Python users just because of
our Vantage Program being built
on Foundry, which is PyCharm, PySpark.
I've got a couple of folks
who do use R fairly regularly in
doing their analysis.
We had a lot of people on
the more legacy programs
looking at SPSS SaaS.
Not to disparage those
but they're expensive.
So we want people getting
on things where they can more
rapidly develop and share.
My team,
we try to use as much
of the existing language and share
code as much as possible.
But it gets difficult.
I think somebody--
[CHUCKLES]
I see Marlene's comment.
I think somebody brought it
up earlier the sensitive nature of
the data that
we're working with.
I mean,
most of our personnel data is
unclassified but it might as well be
SEI-secured compartmentalized information
just because you
have the
personnel--
trying to remember
what PII stands for.
You have that component of
it. You have medical data.
You have HIPAA protections.
You have legal protections.
All these different caveats that
go around any kind of a
soldier data object you create.
So we want people being
able to use the tools--
yes, Personally Identifiable
Information. Thank you, guys.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I had
to go look it up too.
Because I say PII so frequently
I forget what the acronym is.
- No, we speak acronyms. It's
like, we know what it means.
I just don't know
what it stands for.
- [CHUCKLES]
It's funny as
we're covering some
of these questions,
we get to a few of the others
that are asked in the chat
here. But I know on this
topic of PII, Sita, you had a
question in the chat on highly
protected data. Do you want to
expand on that
with your question?
SITA: Sure, thanks,
Kris for answering some of
that already. But I guess,
even talking about breaking
through these different groups,
so different departments
I'm sure have different
things that they consider
are protected or secure.
So how did you deal with
that challenge of trying to be like,
these are the kind of
tools we've built to ensure security
of data within different
departments and to assure that
this is not just all going
to be shared across every team or
every group? And was
that challenging for you?
- So
we really spent a lot of
time working on our data governance,
our policies, and
our protections.
And we spent a lot of time
building that out in the person
event data environment.
It's a secure environment.
You can't download anything.
You can't take anything
out of the environment.
People get fussy about that
because it makes things hard to
access and you've got
to request access through a
project to certain things.
But
that at least, when
people are realizing that
nobody's going to pull
everything into a CSV file or a
spreadsheet that's going to
be sitting on their desktop,
that provides a certain
amount of comfort.
We also
just restricted the access to
any kind of identifiable
information for a lot of
projects unless
it's specifically needed.
So a lot of the work there
can actually be done with
de-identified information.
And we're trying to add
more information back into circulation now,
get people more access now
that we've done the lockdown.
But still, it's always a
little bit of a thing we watch.
- There are so many
great questions piling in here.
Marlene, I see you had
a question in the chat. Do
you want to jump in here?
- Oh, sure.
Hi, Kris, thanks for
joining us today.
I know. I'm so sorry, guys.
Over beers, whoever's going to
posit::conf. We'll
talk about my hiatus.
But I've missed you all dearly.
Even if we've met for
two seconds on these chats,
just know that you guys are
an integral part of my week.
So please take a little
hug for yourself in that.
Anyway, so Kris, I digress.
I'm just interested in what's
like a soft skill that you've
started to really appreciate
from your team here.
Because we always talk a
lot about the technical aspect and
the skills that
are attributed to being a
good programmer and/or data scientist.
But I think there's so much
that has to be focused on about
what aids in all of
that stuff, right?
So what's a soft skill that
maybe you've kind of learned to
appreciate more and
more with your team?
KRIS SALING:
So a lot of it unearthed itself
when we were doing our data
literacy and it's
teaching. I mean,
we have to have people who
have the soft skills that support
being able to teach.
Now it's like,
how can you connect
with somebody,
how can you empathize with them
enough to be able to see where
they're coming from
with their question.
How do you put the
process that you're trying to
describe or the result you're
trying to describe in
a accessible context,
kind of do those
understanding checks. I mean,
it sounds very soft
in this context,
but it's a critical piece
of being able to translate our
solutions to a
decision maker who--
If a decision
maker can't really
use our data or our
decisions to understand it,
it's a tree that
fell in the woods.
So we've really emphasized
that teaching ability.
- Yeah. And I think
something magical happens,
I mean especially for
the rubber ducky programmers,
when you're explaining a
problem to somebody else,
I think some magic--
Yeah, thanks, Libby.
Some magic happens there
even for our understanding and/or
our development of aha
moments. So anyway,
thanks for that chiming
in. I'll pass the baton.
Good to see you again,
Rachael, thanks.
- Yeah.
Thank you all for joining.
So nice to see everybody here.
I'm scrolling up through some
of the questions and thank you
so much to the Posit team
in the background helping me
gather everything. But Ralph,
I see you asked a
question a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah, thank you.
Morning. So Ralph
Asher. I'm a Marine.
And just thinking about
my experience in entry level
training a both as a student
and as an instructor in that,
and it was very industrial,
and it was one size fits all.
And I was curious if anything
that your team is doing is
informing that,
and even maybe before that
in the recruiting environment? Thank you.
- Oh, goodness, I could
speak on that a lot.
I would love to dig into how
we structure our professional
military education so that
it's not the one size fits all.
The way we're rolling out
the different data competencies, I think,
is going to help a little
bit with that because one of the
things we wanted to do was
have all kinds of different levels,
all kinds of different
learning paths,
figure out how to
make this accessible,
and how to make this
apply to people's--
what are they going
to use the most.
Then we front load that to
give them the confidence and
competence they need.
Sometimes,
I mean that's just the
conceptual piece of how to ask
a good data question.
And we workshop with people
through what that looks like.
There's a lot of data
storytelling and how to read
graphs, how to read
statistics, how to be
a good critical consumer of all of
the things that we see in the news.
Then we start getting into
some of the more
hands-on skills. But
at your question--
in terms of your question,
that's something I would
like to go after I think
our Combined Arms Center
Commander General Beagle is
going after that. But
it's a work in progress.
[CHUCKLES]
- And I see Alan
you had a question
about the different teams
working together and we'd love
to have you ask that next.
- Yeah, sure. Thanks, Rachael.
Hi, Kris. I'm curious,
in my experience it's hard
sometimes to be able to
celebrate achievements or
innovative things that folks on
my team do because their
sensitivity about how much we
can share sometimes
even internally,
but for sure externally with
the broader world of data
engineering and data science.
And I imagine that's really acute
for you but I don't know
if that's the right assumption.
I'm curious if you've got ways
to manage that and deal with
that sort of dilemma of how
do you help your team feel like
they belong to a community
but keep the right borders between
oversharing and keeping the
right level of discretion,
and sensitivity, and stuff?
- Yeah, no, that is
an excellent question.
Because one of the things that I've
had to do over the past two, three,
four years is be the army's
spokesperson for people
analytics and how
we're using data,
how we're modernizing
promotions,
how we're doing all this stuff.
A lot of that is extremely
sensitive and it's hard being
able to talk about
what we're doing,
especially to an expert
audience when we can't go into
the nuts and bolts of how
we built out the particular program.
We've really tried to put
together the nuts and bolts in
terms of competencies.
We can talk all day about
how we use text string analysis to
automate the initial screening
for command selection now.
Don't necessarily tell you
the rubric that we're using to
judge these things because we
don't want that to necessarily
get out. That's kind
of a rough example.
But we
do try to be transparent.
And part of being transparent
with the force about
what we're doing
with their data,
especially when it's
their personal data,
is important.
I don't know if that's a
more of a non-answer but
I kind of tap dance around it.
We try to talk about
as much as we can.
- Yeah,
it's interesting to know that
you've got the same dilemma.
And I think I saw
Mark pop up the note,
that kind of question probably holds
for lots of HR analytics stuff
broadly.
Yep.
-
It applies for us in areas
like R&amp;D and how we solve
manufacturing problems and stuff
like that as well.
Tricky to figure out that
right balance. So appreciate it. Thanks.
KRIS SALING: No worries.
We do try to come up with mock
up versions of some of the
algorithms we use that we
can put publicly on Git.
So like there is a
publicly accessible version of the
retention prediction
model we use.
Just the base interval
forecasting engine out on Git.
So the more I think
we can develop those.
Then we also have multi-purpose
models and we can get the
community to critique how we
put it together in the methodology.
- Cool, neat. Thank you.
- I imagine that link to that
Git example is going to
be something people are interested in.
KRIS SALING: Yeah,
as soon as I can,
I'll shoot it over to you cool.
You can share it
with the group. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Yeah, I can put it
up with the recording too.
Awesome. Catherine,
I know you had a question that
touched on what Alan said but I
just wanted to make sure to see
if you wanted to expand on that
a bit or if that answered
your question too.
CATHERINE:
My question of centers around the
fact that this is not a
problem unique to
the army or any
industry in general.
But is there
some sort of higher level
cross-branch innovation for HR,
people leaders that maybe
your team is a part of?
Or do you share any of
that with the Air Force, the Navy,
any of those other kinds of
military organizations that you
might have access to?
- Yeah, so
we reached out to
AppWorks and Softworks.
A lot of their innovation is
not necessarily in how they're building--
they do build a lot of
prototypes the same way we do
for different tools
we're trying to roll out.
But a lot in the
contracting space,
we've had to pull in
expertise in that.
We've talked with the Navy
director of military personnel Management.
And he's very interested in
sharing some of the things that
they've done for my Navy HR
with us and getting a readout
on what we've been doing
for automating and updating our
promotions and performance.
We have a lot of--
and I think this is
probably common everywhere.
We have a lot of these
little networks built
but it's very unofficial. I
don't think you could make
a official innovation
network. Although,
we are tied in with Defense
Innovation Unit and the
National Security Innovation Network
for some of the things
that we're working on.
But the rest of it is
just point to point.
It's a small space
we're working in,
at least on the DOD
side in the army side.
It's a small enough space that we work
in that we know who's working on it.
And if we don't know
somebody personally who's working on a
particular problem, someone
in that network does.
So we've been lucky.
- Thank you.
I see there was an
anonymous question
that said apart from
the NLP that you shared,
what are some other typical
analysis that you do?
- Oops, I lost you
for just a second.
Can you repeat the last
part of that question.
- Sorry. The question was,
apart from the NLP example,
what are some other typical
analysis that you do?
- Well, one of the programs
that we're working on is just
a big neural net
that takes in all our
personnel data and rolls out
a prediction vector of how
likely someone is to retreat
from service over time.
So we do a lot of
retention analysis.
We're trying to figure out
how to improve on an existing
simulation that shows how our
distribution could get backed up.
We want to try to
forecast what our
force is going to look like
or our force inventory is going to
look like over 5 years.
Because obviously you probably heard
in the news about the
recruiting issues.
Issues sounds too kind. But
I'm on camera so I'll just
say recruiting issues.
But that's going to leave a little
bit of a trough in the force.
Even if
we recover from it in the
very near future, it's still going
to be something that we have
to build our inventory around over
the next 5-0 years.
So we want to be able to
take a look at what that looks like
and prioritize skill
development and assignments accordingly.
So we're trying to build
some of those forecasting models.
Then
we're trying to work with
a number of different elements,
working with the Army Software
Factory on just getting data
shared into applications that'll
make it easier for
folks to do things like finding
childcare, PCS, et cetera.
Permanent Change of Station. I
don't want to speak an acronym.
[CHUCKLES]
- Thank you very much.
Let's see. I feel like I'm
firing questions away at you.
We have so many
great questions. Let's see.
- No, they're asking some
great stuff. This is fun.
- [CHUCKLES]
Oh, let's jump over to your
question, [? Dipsha. ?]
Do you to jump in here?
- Sure.
Thanks, Rachael. Thanks, Kris.
I think a lot of it
you've already answered.
But as you started
to build your team,
are there success stories that
you were able to share with
your leadership or other teams
that you're trying to get data
from to say like, look what
we're capable of if you
cooperated to get that
momentum and buy in going?
- Yeah,
that was one of the biggest things
we had to do initially was to show
value. I mean we wanted to
find projects that were kind of
quick wins. That we could say,
hey, look how much easier this
is to answer with data. And
trying to make that
business case to leaders.
One of the things that we used.
I worked for about two years on
a structure to personnel
mismatch program.
Because we were trying to
figure out with all the rapid
changes for Army structure,
why did we have a force
that looked very different from the
structure that we required.
And the answer was obviously,
the senior leaders can say I
want to build this type of
organization. The
requirements are built.
And it takes much longer
for the supply to catch up.
So as an argument for
data-driven talent management
where we look at
attribute-based assignment
versus branch and a grade,
look how much we can reduce the gap
in what we have versus what we assign.
Because we have
these skills here,
they're just coded
under another
specialty. If we make some
of these positions more immaterial,
then we have a lot more
assignment options and the
ability to fill that
talent requirement.
So that one was fairly easy.
We did it with existing data,
existing position analysis.
We have much more in-depth
understanding of the
requirements now.
But we were able to show
very quickly. It's like, OK,
all of these stationing issues
that we think initially were a
problem, much
less of a problem.
- It's a great example.
Thank you, Kris.
- Thank you.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Yeah, thank you. And I
echo [? Arian's ?]
comment,.
Love the idea of quick wins
projects and spending some time
thinking about what those could
be in our own organizations too.
Brad, I see you have
your hand raised here.
Do you want to jump in?
BRAD: Sure.
A lot of focus is being paid
to AI and machine learning,
and data mesh, and data fabric,
and those are, I feel like,
advanced concepts,
like the XYZ in the alphabet.
And if you don't do the ABCs,
the XYZs aren't going
to turn out very well.
Do you guys currently
have a platform around
either data catalog or
governance that helps people
find the right data at
the right time, and the right
reason, and use
it appropriately?
- So
we've rolled one out.
It doesn't have the use that I
would like it to have. It's the
EDSC,
Enterprise Data
Sytem Catalog. So
it should have everything
registered in it that we have
and we're collecting. And
if we could get more
people accessing it,
I think that would go toward
a lot of our problems.
The hard part is we're not
using the tool directly in with
the data systems where
that data is stored.
So we have to
manually update it.
But it's something
that we've considered.
We've identified
that as a need. And
one of the things I'm looking
for is a more intelligent data
catalog that we could roll out.
- I think this question
touches upon this as well,
but George asked what systems are
you using to share data with people?
Is that a different use
than what we're talking about now?
- So a lot of it is
point to point transfer.
We do just extract,
transfer, load. And
we've got a number of our
systems talking to each other
through APIs. But otherwise,
we just have to figure out
all kinds of different ways to get
the data sent to the
Data Science Environment that we're using.
It's not always easy. I mean,
we were at the point
where they were emailing--
or they're not emailing
but where they were physically
mailing hard drives
and we're trying to get
away from that obviously. [CHUCKLES]
- An anonymous question,
interesting question on Slido is,
how does your team build
their own professional portfolios for
when they may move
on to a new job?
Is how can they show what
they've done without sharing protected info?
- Yeah, we've talked
about that a lot. And
the way I've kind of treated
the work my team does and
because I've been in
the position I've been in--
even though this is a new team,
a lot of the team I'm working
with was one I did worked with
for 3 and 1/2 years in Army
Talent Management and with army
people analytics.
And then a couple of
years prior to that in G1.
I treat all my new hires
like they're grad
students coming in.
And they're going to come.
They're going to explore the
data. They're going to get
familiar with the data sets we
use, get familiar with
the business processes.
And then they will find something
that works as a thesis project.
So
what is the thing
that grabs them.
What is the thing that's
the most interesting.
What's most suited to
their capabilities. And
we've really built
things around that.
We've been lucky in that there's been
so much to do that we could
align people to the projects
that they are most interested in.
The thing that we're trying to
work out is what happens if we
have projects that are prioritized
that don't have the same grab.
But that's kind
of how I have it.
I have this whole laundry list of
things that I want to get after.
And
like your grad advisor did
with their research projects like,
hey, let me put you
in this direction.
Go research this a little bit.
Develop this program or this
problem a little bit more and
let's see if that grabs you.
- Yeah, that's an interesting
idea, like the thesis project for
new people coming in.
And I see there's a
conversation happening in the
chat as well about--
well,
adding on to that idea of
quick wins. And then, Alan,
I saw you mentioned something
about how you do onboarding
where people can
contribute right away.
Would you want to jump
in here and share that?
- Sure.
I don't have a ton to add.
We just really try
conscientiously to think about
as someone's coming onto the
team or someone's joining the organization,
how do we set them up
so that they have something meaningful
to contribute as soon as
possible so they don't feel
like they're waiting to become
credible for a year before
people feel like
they can contribute.
And so it's just really
important to give people ways
to feel successful soon.
And Kris,
also reacting to that incoming
grad student kind of approach.
I think that's such an
interesting model to set that
up to say, explore this.
Find something interesting,
dig into it. We'll see if we
can make a project out of it.
It is really cool. And also
appreciate the dilemma of like,
OK, we have to prioritize
that against the portfolio as well.
- No,
I like the idea of
incorporating the quick wins
too because that's
basically the kind of stuff
that new people
could get after.
This one is--
I hate using the term
low-hanging fruit. But this
one's primed, ready to go.
Jump on this, chew on it,
use it to get familiar
with the data,
and then we go and
develop from there.
- OK, I might need help
with this acronym maybe.
A Slido question is, how
have you navigated OPM
requirements as you seek
to modernize recruitment and
retainment strategies?
- Yeah, Office of
Personnel Management.
So we really just
had to get into,
the same way we did
in the military side,
the letter of the
law. It's like,
what do these things actually say
that we must do and what is
written in DOD, or army policy,
or something that's just
more of like a legacy.
We really try to go back
to some of these things and talk
about what the ground truth is.
We haven't really
had much of an issue
modernizing at least on the
data side because of all the
direct hire authorities
that we have.
We've really tried
to push also towards
doing more with term hires,
which scares people in government.
They're like, oh,
you mean they're not going to
make this a career. It's like,
people working in this space
don't want to spend their
lifetime in the
same job anyway.
They're going to come in.
They're going to do a thing.
They're going to
pick a next thing.
And you can see
if that piece is--
that particular position is
validated at the same level.
Because the projects mature.
You might need some entry level
folks or you might need some
folks to do data development
and data cleaning.
And then after that,
you'll realize you've got a
different use for that data,
different project,
he composition of your project
team is going to change.
So we've really tried to use
the most flexible processes we have
within the existing policies.
But we're not afraid to go
up to OSD and say, hey, guys,
we might want to rewrite
this thing a little bit.
Look at what we could
do if you rewrite it.
Here's our proposed
language. Just sign.
- [CHUCKLES]
I noticed in your
bio you talk about
your team conducting research
and doing experiments to
prototype as well. And I
was wondering how do you create
that culture where it's OK
to do these experiments?
Just love to hear a
little bit about that.
- Getting leader buy-out.
Let's not throw a bunch of
money at it. Let's try it first.
I can try it for you for
free and you can figure out how much
money you want to spend
on the result. I mean,
some of them we're looking
at different data integration into
selection boards.
As we are doing that,
we just have the board members
stay on a couple of extra days,
do a quick rundown with them,
and pilot some of the new
look and feel of the board,
and see how much
it changes their
voting from the
previous version.
And we are looking
at things like
voter interreliability.
We're able to explore things that
we haven't been able to explore before.
And then we bring the
findings back. I mean, again,
looking at the quick wins,
we find the things that
are legit findings,
bring those back to senior
leaders and go, hey, guys,
we tested this but look at
all this other stuff we found.
There's more experiments.
Let's go after this.
And we get them excited
about it. We hype it up.
And some of it's like,
it's not necessarily world changing right
from the get go. But again,
the teaching and communicating
piece we were talking about
before. We got to sell
them on like, hey,
this is just step one.
This is just version one.
If we keep developing this,
think about what we could do.
- I love that, that messaging.
That's great.
Caitlin, I see you had
a question here in the chat.
I was thinking it might
be helpful for you to introduce
yourself as well.
[CHUCKLES]
- Yeah. Hi, so I'm Caitlin.
I'm a customer success
rep here at Posit,
and I work with public
sector customers mainly.
So I've done a lot
of work with army,
mainly SOCOM special forces,
Operations Command.
So
that's a little bit about
me. But my question was, so
are there instances
of not having enough
soldier data,
and how currently is HRC
collecting that data?
- I'm sorry, go ahead. I
don't want to cut you off.
- And just to continue on,
how does your team handle
when there's not enough data?
- So we have a ton of data,
doesn't necessarily mean
it's the right data.
And as we're going
through these models,
that was actually what
kicked off our assessment program.
I don't have enough in people's
files to be able to say what
their talent attributes are.
And so we go over to our
research entities at the
Army Research Institute,
Army Research
labs and say, hey,
you guys got any kind of
existing studies that we can
peel a couple things off
of and take a look at,
and maybe experiment, and
go collect some more data
with you guys on this.
And we've had a really
good partnership with them on it.
It's also allowed them
to modernize how they're
approaching research because they've
got these things that
they can peel off and show
quick wins from their findings. Rather than,
it's this five-year study that
all the leadership is going to
change out before it's
done. And leadership,
they generally treat
that with distrust.
- Kris, I saw something
you had posted on LinkedIn,
I think it was maybe
a few days ago,
about the importance of being able
to take time off and to be
fully off during that time.
And I saw you were asking
some advice to other people
from your LinkedIn network
too. And I was just wondering
what your thoughts
are on that and what
you're learning from
your own network too.
- Well, that's the fun
part about this network.
I love throwing questions out there
and just saying, hey, guys, I'm human.
I do a lot of things right.
And I've been put in
a position because--
you can wave your awesome
flag all day but it's also,
I screw up a lot of things.
I am horrible at
taking time off.
I will compulsively go
and check things if not--
I've got Mike [? Carroll, ?]
who's our lead for procurement,
but he's also my accountability
buddy. He's just like,
I see you. I see you on
Teams, get off, go home.
So I love throwing things like
that out to the community and
just saying, hey,
I'm not the only person
who's dealing with this.
And this is a professional
wellness thing.
And I think all of us can
benefit from the discussion on.
Let me throw it out there. You
guys tell me what works for you.
And a lot of it came back
that same thing. It's like,
we need that time to
do an active or inactive recharge.
Sometimes, it's doing
yoga or cross training.
When you've been trying
to ramp up for a race,
you've got to do something
but make it something that's not
work. So
trying to figure out those
good substitutions or those
complementary activities.
And we talked earlier about was
one of my favorite things to
do, not at work. I love
hiking, love cooking,
love going to the beach.
And I think we've got to
let ourselves know that not only is
it OK to have hobbies,
not everything has to
be work and hustle.
But those things actually
complement your ability to
refresh, recharge,
and do your job.
So I think it's hugely
important and I'm always trying
to figure out ways
to get better at it.
- I love that idea of having
an accountability buddy too.
And when we see
our friends at work
on Slack, or on Teams,
or whatever when they're supposed
to be off, just saying, hey--
- Like what are you
doing here. Go away.
[CHUCKLING]
My boss is really good at that.
General [? Joe, ?]
he'll see me on Teams. He
goes, why are you on Teams?
Go be with your
family. Go away.
And so conversely, I'm just
like, you better be TUI, boss,
because otherwise, why
are you calling me?
- Right.
Mike, I see you had a question
in the chat a bit earlier. You
want to jump in here?
- No, not really, because now my
focus is on this paid time off
question.
I think we should carry on with
that thread rather than [? jump ?] [? back.
?]
- Well, OK. Anybody else have
thoughts to share on that?
- I see a lot popping up
in the chat resources.
- OK. So since you called
me out Rachael, I'll jump. So
this is a personal experience.
And I agree wholeheartedly that
time off should be
time away from work.
But
the
personal anecdote is,
how many times do I
see a quick question--
hey, I've got a quick
question on Teams.
And I'm like, oh, yeah,
I can answer that.
And it'll only take
a couple of minutes.
And I'll just help this
because that will unblock that person.
So you just fire
off a quick, oh,
this is where you
find that thing.
But the other thing is
that if you don't do that,
they don't sit there blocked
for the 24, 48, 72 week
long that you're
not at the office.
They find the
solution themselves.
So it's almost like, well, yes,
I've been very helpful and
I've answered this question quickly.
But actually,
I've taken my brain from doing
the thing that I was doing to
answering a work question.
And then I've got
to come back to the
out of office brain. It's hard. KRIS
SALING: I think
there's a--
well, there's a big
part to that too,
where it's like a
little bit of parking
the wanting to be helpful but
also there are lots of people
who could do this.
There are a lot of
people who could answer this question.
Or there are lots of people--
Like in my team, I've
got a team of amazing,
awesome people who can
handle almost 99.9%
of the things out there.
There's a little bit of guilt,
am I dumping my work off on
somebody else for this time I'm taking off.
But at the same time, it's just
like, I need to give them the
same respect when they
go on leave. And no,
they're not dumping
off their work.
I'm helping them carry stuff or
at least put it in a holding
pattern until they get back.
- I've noticed with
taking time off,
I can't use that time to
read work books either. Because then
I will be on the beach
thinking about, oh,
I should work on this project
or oh, here's an idea.
I want to go write it down.
But Jonathan,
I see you had some thoughts
about this in the chat, too.
Do you want to jump in?
Or you don't have to.
You can keep it in
the chat too. OK.
JONATHAN: Yeah, I'm
a strong advocate of people
being away when they're away.
And something
that I've noticed,
people will use your email
inbox as a placeholder for
things that they want you
to address when you come back.
So you come back to an
inbox of 350 emails.
A mixed bag of
things that you need,
things that you
don't need to see,
things that you're copied on just for
an FYI. So I put in my
out-of-office explicitly that I'm
not responding to anything
that's sent while I'm on PTO.
And that if people want
me to address something
to just delay send
it until I get back.
- Yeah, delay send is
a awesome function.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
That's a great idea.
I hadn't thought
of that before.
I've seen some people's out
of office say something about
adding urgent to the subject
line so they know which emails
they need to get to first.
But delaying sounds
better. [CHUCKLES]
Let's see,
any other thoughts on this
topic before we shift gears?
Seth, I see you had some
thoughts on this.
SETH: Yeah,
that just got brought up exact
like 5 seconds after I wrote
that. But it's good to know
that someone else likes that too.
[CHUCKLING]
- Great. Well,
keep sharing the resources and
ideas there in the chat too.
When
we get to the last
10 minutes here,
I want to remind people
if there were questions earlier
that we maybe missed in
the chat or a mid conversation,
feel free to raise your hand
here on Zoom or maybe even just
copy and paste those questions over just
so we see them again there too.
KRIS SALING: More if the
chat's rocking and rolling.
- Yeah, we always have a
big party there in the chat.
Caitlin, I think you had
another question a little bit earlier.
- Yeah. I just wanted
to ask, are there any
impacts that the army has
changed due to the work with
this new team that you
have or maybe people analytics that
team that we see in the
army today that are directly from
the work that you were doing?
-
I think the biggest one is
just getting rid of the additional
selection boards. I mean,
we've taken those and that's about
up to eight weeks of time
where we have a bunch of
GOs sitting in a room. It's just
like, OK, they're going into
an assessment based on this
invitation that's going to
get the in-depth detail.
And they're going to
go into interviews.
They're going to go
into all these things.
The file scrub, the automatic
scoring of these things that
they spent all this time on,
they don't need to do that.
We can automate that.
And we automate it.
We validate it with the
branches to make sure it makes
sense. We get that
human back in the loop.
But that's going to free up a
ton of time but it has also
uncovered a lot of things that
we need to do with performance management.
Otherwise, I mean, just
the introduction of the two-way
market that HRC is using
to preference assignments.
We're about to
pilot a randomized controlled
trial for retention incentives
using the retention prediction model
that we have as kind of
an a priori statistical
indicator whether or not
someone is likely to attrit.
And then if they take one
of these incentives and sign an
additional duty service
obligation, we know that's a
win. We can get a statistical
lift prediction from these
pilots on how likely these
different incentives are to keep people.
So I think once we
get that rolled out,
it's going to have
a lot of impact.
But we're at the point
where we've got the model built.
We've got the retention
incentives picked.
Now it's time to
do the experiment.
- Great, that's awesome.
I'm really looking forward to
seeing all of these changes
happen for the army.
Also, actually,
for those on the call today,
I work part time for the
Texas Army National Guard.
So I definitely have a personal
side interest in all the work
that Kris is doing.
So thank you.
KRIS SALING: No, thank you.
- Kris,
I thought it might be
interesting to learn a little
bit more about your
own personal journey
in getting into this role
of leading the HRC
2030 vision. And I
was wondering like was
there a specific moment or
something that led you to
wanting to lead this initiative?
- It was an
interesting ramp up.
Because my undergrad was
in operations research.
I commissioned as an engineer
so I really didn't touch
anything until I went
back to grad school.
I went back to grad
school and studied complexity science.
So I was doing
rare event simulation, probabilistic design,
stuff that doesn't really
come into the people enterprise.
Went and taught that at
West Point for a while.
And then my first job as an
operations research and systems
analyst was working theater
security cooperation and
building partner capacity,
counterterrorism
stuff for INDOPACOM.
Then my branch pulled a
fast one on me and said,
we're going to send you to
the Army G1. I was like, what
are you sending me
to G1 for?
I don't know anything
about HR. I don't know.
I'm not a personnel
analyst. OK, well,
I guess I better
figure this out.
And that
was the best thing that
could have happened to me,
because I was the Napoleon's
corporal sitting there in the
corner going, why do
you do this? What is it?
This doesn't make sense.
Why is this thing here?
Why are we using Excel
spreadsheets where we've got an
environment where you
can house all this--
oh, because it doesn't
have the data in it.
How do I get the
data put in it? And
this is kind of the
culmination of eight years of curiosity,
and building things,
and asking questions,
and trying to get
things simulated,
and big problems in a space
that wasn't really heavy in the
data sphere being
answered by data.
And now we've got Secretary's
focus on it. We have
a lot of different focuses
coming in that are leading us
to be more data driven.
And when the opportunity came up
to not just keep working on it--
Because I started people analytics. Then
it's like, all right, we got--
I didn't start it
completely from scratch.
We took the human capital big
data program and rolled it up
under an existing office
that was actually going to
make use and figure out how
to build some serious models out
of some of this
data we were using.
I did the same thing when
I was at talent management.
I built a little startup within
there that was churning out all
these data products. And to me,
this was the opportunity to
do the same thing within HRC,
is to sell my other startup
to corporate and I'm going to go
over and do this
other little startup.
- I love just thinking of you
asking all those questions
there, like why are we
doing it this way. And
it's making me think of a
question I love to ask people.
Is there a piece of career
advice that you've either given
or received that you'd
like to share with us?
-
It's a tricky one to give
especially in the army where
your first five to eight
years, it's all about conformity and
compliance. And after that,
all of a sudden they expect you
to flip a switch and go, OK,
now you're in charge
of things, be creative.
And there are a lot of people
who just get gummed up in the
works. They don't
know how to do it.
I tell people to find--
we were talking about the
hobbies and the other things
that we will do to
exercise our creative energy, those opposite
mental muscles.
And I just tell people,
it's going to sound silly,
but exercise your
creative pursuits.
Find a way to exercise that
creative energy so that you can keep
the brain flexible.
Especially if you want to
go into spaces like this where
it's not charted,
it's very ambiguous.
There's not a whole lot of--
I mean, the last three
jobs I had didn't exist.
They were created and I got
stuck in them. And there's no
book. There's no notes.
There's no anything about how
to do this particular job.
I mean, so I had to go out--
Just like we were
talking about before,
if you're not there
to answer a question,
the person's going to
go find the answers.
So I'm going to go out
and talk to other HR professionals and
see how they're doing this.
I'm going to go talk
to other data science professionals and
see how they're doing
this and put together
a hodgepodge answer to
try out and experiment.
And I mean this is just
a great place for it.
And I saw it pop
up in the comments,
data science is a great
place to be curious.
If I were in my home office,
I have a poster of Sherlock
Holmes from the movie up behind
because he's always going,
data, data, data. I need data.
I need to solve problems. I
want to go and dig into this.
I want to solve a case.
I'm going to be a
data detective. So
it just gets you excited.
I mean, find a way to exercise
those creative pursuits
because they're fun. And
I think you'll use those to
find that kind of creative fun
in your work also.
- I love that. Thank
you, Kris. And I can
hear the excitement from you as
you're explaining that too. I love it.
KRIS SALING: I love
my job. I won't lie.
[CHUCKLING]
-
I know we have a few
minutes here but one other question
that was asked anonymously was,
how do you stay updated
with the latest and greatest tech
that you can use and
enable your team with?
- Conversations like
this. Getting out to--
I've made the argument
that the army--
because we pulled back
on conferences for a while.
We need to go to
professional conferences.
industry conferences.
We need to go talk to people
who are doing this work.
We need to go back to school.
We need to go do
training with industry.
We need to be able to go
and find the people who are leading
the edge and create those
networks so when we do have a
problem and we're like OK, what
is the industry doing, we go,
who's leading in this edge.
What kind of technology can
we take or what do we need to
develop and how do we do it,
that you've got to phone,
a friend available. And
I won't say I'm always the
most up to date.
And I have a little bit of
a pass from the army just because
a lot of our stuff is
legacy and it doesn't necessarily take
the most cutting edge thing
to solve those problems.
But I do like knowing what's going
on and where the field is going.
- Absolutely. We keep a
running list of books
and recommendations from
Data Science
Hangout. Leaders
and everybody here--
well, when I say we, Libby
is actually the one doing it.
So do you have any
recommendations for books or
things you're reading
now we should check out?
- I've got a whole
laundry list.
[CHUCKLES]
It's probably been
brought up a few times,
but if you're doing any
kind of transformation and
modernization,
The Unicorn
Project is a must read.
I'm reading
Further, Faster,
and Far
Less Drama
by Janice Fraser right now.
It's about change
management and transforming organizations.
That's another good one. And
I got recommended Jeff
Baer's--
I think that's who it
was by. It's called Hug Your
Haters. And it's
about customer experience and
customer service. But the reason I
love it is it teaches you to
actively seek out criticism and
critics and find the people who
are just making noise,
but also find the ones who
have a legitimate complaint and
figure out how you can solve
their problems for them.
So I love that.
- Thank you for reminding
me of that book.
I heard of it a few months
ago and completely forgot.
I need to go add
that to the list too.
-
I see lots of good detective
books popping up in the chat too.
- Yeah, it seems like there's a
lot of us here who wanted to be
detectives or Sherlock Holmes,
Nancy Drew at some
point in our life.
[CHUCKLES]
So it probably has
some relation-- KRIS
SALING: This is kind of what
we do. We're finding clues. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: --to
data. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
Well, thank you so much,
Kris, for joining us today.
It's been a pleasure hearing
from you and learning from your
experience. Thank you
for all that you do.
KRIS SALING: Thank you so
much for letting me join.
This is awesome.
- Have a great rest
of the day everybody.
Thanks so much for joining us.
We'll see you all next week.
SPEAKER: Cheers.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Bye, everybody. everybody.